[Music]
so what I'd like to do tonight is to
talk about the difference between
science and pseudoscience which is gonna
be more complicated than you might think
in some cases it's pretty
straightforward in the interesting cases
it isn't and we're gonna spend some time
talking about the interesting cases and
then we're gonna talk about not you know
I'm not gonna do anything about how to
debunk astrology or UFOs or something
like that because if you believe in
astrology there is no point for me in
the bunking them here if you don't
believe in astrology there is no point
in me your telling you why you shouldn't
believe in a search so we're actually
gonna talk about something else that is
related to the general topic which is
how do we deal with finding truth who we
trust who we don't trust what what kind
of heart can we navigate a world that is
increasingly affected by fake news and
an alternative facts and so on and so
what I just found out via my Twitter
feed which is what I get most of my News
that Samsung has just developed a piece
of soft a new piece of software that
allows somebody to capture a still image
of you and create a fake video where you
can be made to say whatever the hell
they want you to say that seems like a
horrible development to me yay for
technology all right so what's the
problem that we're not going to talk
about in the next few minutes well this
is the simple version of the problem
astrology over here astronomy over there
pseudoscience science if you have
trouble with this I think you're in the
wrong place
okay but that's the problem the problem
is you know how do we tell them apart me
why is it that it's that in increase in
some cases we can say yeah this is
really not sign whatever it is it's not
science and in other case we can say
yeah sure of course it is and then what
happens in between are there situations
where you kind of yeah you go like this
and so you'll see in a minute there are
the second question is why do we care
all right what's the practical import of
all of this well I think that there are
three major answers to why we care about
what philosophers of science refer to as
a demarcation problem how to delineate
two separate science from non science
and in particular science from
pseudoscience well first of all because
I think it's an interesting intellectual
problem I got man I'm curious I'm a
philosopher so I'm and I'm a scientist
so I'm curious to see what exactly how
do we cash out this thing now this is
probably the least convincing argument
for the simple reason that whenever you
approach an academic and you ask them so
why did you spend the last 20 years of
your life and you know five million
dollars studying the sexual habits of a
mouse in the middle of Panama the
typical answer is because it's
intrinsically interesting by which they
mean it interests me right and that's
enough of a reason and it is as far as
I'm concerned I could stop here but in
fact as far as most people are concerned
the other two answers are much more
important one is science costs money a
lot of money and much of that money not
all of it but a lot of that money does
come from taxpayers so it is only fair
especially in democratic or pseudo
democratic countries that we question as
people as you know as the public's like
well why are we spending money on this
kind of thing and is this thing actually
science is this thing actually useful is
this thing actually well done there are
examples where you could question that
for instance for a number of years now
in these United States the National
Institute of Health has put several
millions of dollars into the study of
so-called alternative medicine and you
know you may or may not agree that
that's a good use of taxpayers money
depending on how you think about
alternative medicine what do you think
it is
alternative medicine this is a
spectacular case that took
that took place a number of years ago
when the United States was about to
build the what later became the Large
Hadron Collider which is this gigantic
particle smasher which was eventually
built in in Geneva under an
international consortium initially it
was supposed to be built in Texas
because you know Texas is about big
things so of course they had to that to
have the largest particle accelerator in
the world they already dug the hole
which by itself cost a billion dollars
just to dig a hole right big hole and so
there was a congressional hearing and a
number of senators were kind of
questioning a number of high-profile
physicists and there was this famous
exchange between one of the senators and
Steven Weinberg Nobel for physics where
the senator said you know the problem is
professor Weinberg I cannot justify this
kind of expense with my taxpayers
because they don't eat quarks to which
Weinberg made a big show of taking a
napkin in a pen and a pen and doing a
back of the envelope calculation and
then he looked up at the center and said
actually senator by my calculation rough
as it is each one of your constituents
that does heat several billion quarks
every morning for breakfast it was a
very funny retort he didn't get in the
funding about the third reason thank you
the third reason is because contra
popular perception pseudoscience
actually does hurt at least some
pseudoscience dessert and in some cases
it actually kills there is a woman here
on the cover of mothering magazine that
has a big know AZT tattoo on or pregnant
belly a CT of course is a cocktail of
drugs that is used is most efficient way
to counter the hiv/aids developmental
hiv/aids and the reason she has that
tattoo is because she is a hiv/aids
denialists she does not believe that
there is a causal connection between HIV
virus and development of AIDS you know
what the result of that lack of belief
was she's dead and so is her child right
so pseudoscience does kill
it does have health consequences right
now in the United States and not in
parts of Europe there is a resurgence of
measles for instance and other things
that are caused by the fact that people
all of us haven't gone into their mind
that vaccination is not one of the most
important advances in medicine in the
twentieth century it's actually you know
not helping so these things do matter if
we're not talking just about people
reading the otoscope in the morning for
fun that doesn't have much consequences
unless you actually invest your money
based on what the astrologer tells you
although they are you probably not gonna
be and doing any worse than if an
economist told you okay I'm going to
spend a little bit of time on this slide
but the stock doesn't have a lot of
slides but they're kind of full of stuff
to talk about this is probably the most
important one so here's what you're
looking at this is my conceptual map of
the landscape that separates science
from pseudoscience over here on the
horizontal axis axis you have a some
kind of measure of theoretical
understanding or sophistication of a
particular field over here you have a
some measure of empirical knowledge
empirical content of that field now
those are the two things that tend to
define good scientists good science good
science is both theoretically and
empirically very high it's very rich in
content right so along these two axes we
can actually fairly easily separate
really solid science from really solid
if that's the term pseudoscience so
let's start there with the simple
examples and then it gets more
complicated and more interesting so
right over here you get particle physics
evolution biology that sort of stuff
those are sciences nobody disagrees
nobody's ever suggested that particle
physics is a pseudoscience there's this
that's it and why is it well because it
is the most sophisticated theoretical
science that we have quantum mechanical
theory is the most sophisticated theory
in all of science in all times and I say
that as a non physicist so you know
trust me if a biologist tells you that
you can't even trust me although we'll
get back to the issue of trust in a
minute and it's also got a large amount
of empirical verification I mean you can
do experiments in quantum mechanics and
results come out exactly as the theory
predicts it to many many decimal points
precision it's it's a science it's as
good as the science can get at the
opposite extreme we have already
mentioned HIV denialism astrology
intelligent design creation theory that
sort of stuff those are areas where the
theoretical understanding is no or very
close to note there is not much there
intelligent design theory for instance
it's a misnomer there is no theory the
theory boils down to three words God did
it that's the extent of the theory there
is nothing else there right it's a
little not enough neat but also they
have no empirical content meaning that
in fact the empirical content if
anything is negative there is nothing
there to support whatever the notion is
or very little to support whatever the
notion is so here and here the thing is
easy pseudoscience over there science
over there what about these all other
stuff over here well that's where things
get complicated and interesting so these
are fields that have either intermediate
degrees of theoretical sophistication or
intermediate degrees of empirical
content or both now I'm not gonna go
through all of them but it besides even
this is just a sample there's a lot more
but let me give you a couple of examples
for instance SETI the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence I'm a fan
my computer has a safe you know
screensaver that actually is a algorithm
is it's it's a program that actually
crunches data for on behalf of the cedi
program and then sends them up to their
server so that hopefully I'll be the
first one to detect a signal from an
intelligent civilization
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV